that were right over
here Elon Musk went to Israel and Ted uh
some of the areas in the South that were
attacked by Hamas I want to show you a
quick clip of that into the K
itself this is the house
of on his way back you notice several
terrorists that were right over
here it's uh it's a symbol in Boots you
have kids inside mothers and the fathers
around with it but it's holding
shells specifically of
a that was used here in order to protect
here's a little more video of a mother
who had her son uh kidnapped by Hamas
showing the video to uh to
Elon no audio on this one but here she
is showing the actual video and he there
he is he's he's just watching it he also
watched the 47 minute there's a 47
minute compilation video of the
atrocities that that we're we're not
even going to show you here I mean the
stuff literally it is it literally
happened there are many journalists who
have verified it Elon has now seen it
them cutting open a pregnant woman and
taking the fetus out and letting her
bleed out as they showed the baby to her
I mean things that are if they were in
the movie Saw you would say this one is
too over the top uh here is Elon Musk
now talking about uh a better way to uh
to go ahead and and how do you figure
out what's going to happen to Gaza in
the future it was uh certainly been
um a day I would say an
emotionally difficult day uh to see the
places where people were murdered I just
did a talk with the the Prime Minister
and um I think there's I mean obviously
there are three things that need to
happen uh in in the Gaza situation I
mean there's no choice but
to kill those who insist on murdering
civilians there's no choice um they're
not going to change their mind but and
then the second thing is to change the
the education so that a new generation
of of murderers is not trained to be
murderers and then the and then the
third thing which is also very important
is to try to build
Prosperity you know it's interesting
because he's right of course and this is
what Israel stated goal is right the
goal is you must kill every Hamas member
period and you're going to have to kill
the ones that are in Qatar too the
billionaires who are running the thing
you're going to have to kill all of them
so it was great to see some moral
Clarity it was great to see someone
picking aide that was number one then
you have to change the education system
by the way he could be talking about
America in this case too right you have
to change it so you don't grow
generation after generation with all of
the wrong ideas and who are breeding
other murderers and all those things and
then the third one which is the most
interesting one to me is that you have
to fix the economic situation now the
irony of that is that that's exactly
what Israel tried to do when they left
right they left them with green houses
they had they left them with uh
infrastructure the UN and all and The
Who and all of these organiz
organizations they put billions
literally billions with a bee worth of
dollars into the Gaza Strip so that they
could build a fully free functioning
society and the Israelis said we want
nothing to do with you freaks but what
did they do they decided to build a
freaking War Machine and the war machine
is actually quite effective at spreading
Mayhem and medieval barbarity and
everything else uh so Elon is right
about that the problem is this is like a
chicken or the egg situation if you
still have all of these people who want
the murder want the Mayhem want to meet
the 72 virgins and everything else then
what are you going to do uh here's audio
uh Elon uh talking about how Hamas is
actually anti-human and when you have an
anti-h human Force there really is only
one thing you can do with that if you
want peace destroy Kamas if you want
security destroy Kamas if you want a
better life for the Palestinians in Gaza
who've been hijacked uh by Hamas destroy
Hamas U all of that is a precursor to
the question that you asked you first
have to get rid of the poisonous regime
uh as you did in Germany as you did in
Japan in World War II these were two
there's no choice there's no choice
that's a prerequisite yes there's no
choice isn't that interesting it's not
that hard to take a stand it's not that
hard to pick aside there's no choice
these people are here to destroy
everything that is good they are here to
kill people and murder people and kidnap
people and do things that we could not
have possibly imagined humans could do
less than two months
ago